joe rogan announced that he's moving to
texas
and i want to get this i want to get
this
uh out because i i think there's a lot
of people
that don't know the full story joe
wants to go there for a little more
freedom he said and because la
you know you have the homelessness and
the traffic here's the actual reality
i moved to l.a about a year ago and i
immediately started making more money
than joe
on as a podcaster i was i'm doing better
than him
our youtube views are higher than his uh
my subscribers are more than his
my ad deals are more than his um in the
beginning that was okay but it became
awkward
for us for our friendship it was weird
to see him at the comedy store
um because i was making more money as a
pot i was a bigger podcaster
in a year of being in los angeles um my
our podcast regularly get 30 to 50
million views
per podcast and he gets i believe
maybe 2 million or 5 million or
something it's
pathetic so he's now running to texas
he's running away from me because i have
taken over los angeles
and i am the biggest podcaster in the
world and
i you know for him to go out and pretend
that this is about traffic
is a little absurd um i i came
i saw i conquered and he is choosing to
run away
that's the reality he doesn't have any
money he asked me to borrow 300
last week and i said no um
that's it i i will not enable people and
their poor decisions uh this spotify
deal is not real spotify does not exist
i have google spotify i don't know what
it is
i don't think by the way neither does
spotify if they exist they don't know
what it is
i don't know what it is i don't know
what this last podcast on the left is
that got some d i don't know what these
things are
i'm pretty sure they're inventions i
don't fall for it
okay so when i come to la and i take it
over
just admit that you got beat
don't start talking about homeless
people in traffic
okay i'm number one now number one you
hear that
hashtag only comedy store regular not in
jail
it's a joke relax
i never knew what i never thought i'd
know what it's like to own a city
now i do out i'll be deciding who stays
and who goes